neogaf is a carpet a son posted an image  of what is allegedly the rumored new  model of the xbox one called Xbox one f  the xbox one s looks to be smaller and  more compact than the original model  which makes sense since it's plated to  be forty percent smaller than the  standard xbox one the new console also  appears to have an infrared blaster  included at its base which might be to  use with TV remotes the leaked image  states that the xbox one else will have  a two terabyte hard drive and support  HDR and 4k video it's also said that it  will include a vertical stand the Neo  Catholic in question was later affirmed  by Kotaku's Jason shreya so considering  the bevy of corroborated rumors this one  is feeling pretty likely let me know in  that comment box how you feel about this  possible new Xbox one model and stay  tuned to games but for all the latest  III news  you